what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
and Spider-Man across the spider-verse
is right around the corner only a week
away technically the release date is
June 2nd but of course many theaters
show it on June 1st which is a week away
so not much longer to wait and last
night they showed screenings for across
the spider verse and the reactions are
in and I haven't seen a single negative
one yet now if you liked the first movie
Into The spider-verse it's been said
before the reviews even came out that
this movie was going to be even better
than the first one and the first one was
amazing so this one has to be just Top
Notch and I have a lot of friends who
went and saw it so we'll talk about what
they said as well as some other industry
insiders reporters and journalists as
well now there are a few different
things to consider when listening to
these reactions because one is animation
this is kind of a different animation
style than we're really used to it's
very comic like and again if you've seen
the first one or if you've seen the
trailers you know but I mentioned that
because they said the animation was
going to get stepped up in this film and
according to these reviews and reactions
it has but of course you can't forget
about the story obviously the story is
very enticing there's the Multiverse or
spider-verse and there's now the Hub of
the spider-verse and we're seeing all of
these different Spider-Man variations
interact with Miles Morales we also know
from the trailers that Spider-Man 2099
has beef with Miles Morales because he's
not willing to make some sacrifices in
his own Universe which could therefore
affect the entire universe so Spider-Man
2099 has kind of ordered all the other
Spider-Man variants to get a hold of
miles and kind of keep in prisoner so
that alone is a really enticing story
but they also came out and told us that
at the heart of this story it's a love
story between miles and Gwen and Gwen
Stacy spider-gwen is one of my favorite
characters ever not just Spider-Man
characters but Marvel in general so
we'll hear about the story and we'll
hear about the animation in these
reviews so let's dive in first we'll
start off with one of my best buds over
at the real rejects Gregory Alba who
said after watching Spider-Man across
the spider-verse holy holy holy didn't
want it to end no amount of trailer
footage prepares you for this avoid
spoilers as much as you can and of
course just to mention we will not be
going over any spoilers in this video
none of the reactions or reviews have
spoilers in them yet and I'm pretty sure
if they did it would not be asked to see
another single screening of a movie
again from the studio but personally
knowing Greg very well that is an insane
response to a movie from him which means
it's pretty dang good now I'm not gonna
say more because he's going to do his
own video so check him out over at the
real rejects but one thing that he told
me was its bigger Stakes crazier film
yet is more personal and intimate than
the last film which I'm really looking
forward to because that sounds amazing
also another reaction from one of the
real Rejects and friend of mine as well
koi jondro said this the best Spider-Man
movie ever made comes out next week
across the spider-verse transcends
comics movies words I am overwhelmed
with emotioned I am enamored I am the
happiest I have ever been as a
Spider-Man fan and that is saying
something if you know Koi Koi knows his
stuff he really and truly does and to
hear him say that this was the best
Spider-Man movie ever that's big and
gets me just super pumped for the movie
also one of my close friends Laura
sirakul saw it and said this
OMG Spider-Man across the spider-verse
is mind-blowing the animation the
writing the music and everything is
simply amazing I'm not even over hyping
it it deserves the hype OMG they did it
again now one thing that Laura mentioned
that I really like is the writing and
the music the animation alone is going
to get a lot of hype we're going to hear
that a lot in reviews and reactions and
it's just expected now it's great that
it lives up to the expectation but the
writing had to live up to it as well and
the music was a big part of the first
movie so it seems like everything that
we loved about the first movie is even
better in the second movie alright so
those were a few of my personal friends
who have seen the movie let's talk about
some other outlets who have seen the
movie as well Stephen Weintraub or
Frosty from collider said this
absolutely loved Spider-Man across the
spider-verse wanted to push pause about
a hundred times to study the incredible
Artistry on display cannot recommend
this film enough and already looking
forward to seeing it again next time in
IMAX and yeah based off of what we've
seen from the trailers and what we know
the first movie to be this movie is
going to be visually insane and you
really Gotta Give It Up to the VFX team
because this animation truly is
beautiful then coming from Drew Taylor
who is a reporter for for the rap He
said this Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is a stunning achievement
yes it's visually dazzling with
expansive expressive new Realms Gwen's
world is my favorite but the movie's
real superpower is its emotional depth
and its beautiful melancholic tone I
love this movie so much now I like this
reaction because again we know that the
movie is going to visually look amazing
we've already seen it in the trailers
it's fantastic already but talking about
the emotional depth makes me really
excited because I am really excited to
see some of the relationships in this
movie like between Gwen and miles
between Gwen and spider Punk because we
know that there's a little bit of
jealousy there with miles plus not to
mention miles's parents it looks like
miles's Dad might have to die just based
off of what we've seen from the trailers
so I'm ready to not only be amazed by
what we see but also the story as well
then we have one from Aaron Perrine over
at Phase zero slash comicbook.com
stating Spider-Man across the the
spiderverse lives up to the hype in
every conceivable Way Miles Morales
absolutely shines in his second Marvel
movie Adventure When Stacy takes her
place at the head of this table too tons
of heart on display in every corner of
this one spider Punk Spider-Man 2099 and
Spider-Man India will be instant
favorites along with a couple of massive
surprises that we won't spoil here
needless to say spider-verse is my
favorite movie of the year so far and
the sequel is a master class in every
conceivable way that's some pretty High
Praise there as well and I'm glad
they're actually putting focus on some
other Spider-Man variants as well
obviously not all of them since we've
seen hundreds of them so far in the
trailer but it's nice to see that a few
of them do get to shine but Miles
Morales still means the focus as far as
those massive cameos spoilers are
concerned I think we all might be
thinking the same thing I won't say it
in case you're not but yeah now to end
it I will go back to a tweet from a
friend of the Channel's Brandon Davis
over at Comic dot com because he stated
across the spider-verse is simply an
incredible accomplishment it's stunning
but also very much an unfinished Story
by its end he also said it's everything
a Spider-Man fan could ask for and much
more so good it's hard to believe it
exists but I wanted to talk about this
one because he says it's an unfinished
story and remember there is a beyond the
spider verse coming eventually so this
is not the finale this isn't the last
across the spider-verse film there is
another sequel coming to this one so
keep that in mind if you love this movie
coming up which it sounds like a lot of
people are going to we still get one
more film at least one more that's
planned they could keep this thing going
for a long time but beyond the
spider-verse is planned and hopefully
it's even better than this movie that is
supposedly better than the first one but
we'll have to wait and see like I said
we're less than a week away let me know
how excited you are for Spider-Man
across the spider-verse in the comments
down below and if you have a favorite
spot Spider-Man let us know who your
favorite Spider-Man is don't forget to
like the video and if you subscribe and
leave a comment down below you enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well we pick a
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item also if you
like the channel and would like to
support it we now have a patreon account
we appreciate all the support we've
gotten so far we also have a website
which we post to every single day and a
Discord server with fellow like-minded
superhero lovers will link all of those
in the comments in the description down
below and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
me